le président à ma question s'adresse de
nouveau à monsieur le haut commissaire
en charge des retraites
une chose est certaine les régimes de
retraite doivent être réformées je vous
le dis d'autant plus que notre famille
politique à assumer des réformes
courageuses dans ce domaine il ya eu la
réforme balladur
la réforme fillon la réforme woerth il
faut rendre à césar ce qui est à césar
si réforme ont sauvé de la faillite le
régime de retraite de nos compatriotes
car elles ont le courage de toucher à la
durée des cotisations
même si ça ne plaît pas à tout le monde
sur ces ronds vous avez ce matin tenter
d'éclairer monsieur le premier ministre
nos concitoyens sur votre projet au delà
des grands principes pas vraiment
nouveau sous lequel vous avez appuyé vos
propos je voudrais vous poser cinq
questions précises qui reste en surpris
en suspens
la première à quel âge les français
pourront-ils bénéficier d'une pension de
reversions la deuxième que devient dans
l'autre réforme dans votre réforme la
majoration de trimestres dont
bénéficient les mères de famille et elle
supprimée
que devient la majoration de 10 % par
par an pour les familles de trois
enfants la troisième
que deviennent les réserves des régimes
des salariés du privé vous avez
simplement évoqué l'avenir des réserves
des régimes des professions libérales la
quatrième le bonus malus malus
s'appliquera tic dès 2022
et si oui s'appliquera-t-il aux régimes
spéciaux et enfin les salariés
pourront-ils comme aujourd'hui
bénéficier d'une reconstitution de
carrière complète à 67 ans